welcome to this video and playing zawa
crowd they were called again now with
the German like this guy is traveling a
lot and he's on to 651 this is really
high usually is playing the Kings Indian
often with c6 not this time I again I go
for each three a six-year this is some
intending to to to play a bang co-star
c5 and so on c5 and b5
I think you can just ignore it b5 and
Castle this is so similar to what was
recently played in the game our own yarn
against Nakamura and this us tournament
the sink filled Cup hmm this is so
uncommon closing it up you cannot play
me five here because of takes a TV 5 at
least I hope because he's played age six
and this is some problem okay he's
attacking here I have a temper yeah to
be honest this this whole position looks
very bad for black very passive but ok
still needs to be played how to do this
I'm even a 3 as a good move yeah we're
not actually threatening to take and get
get them out came this was my idea now
keep it closed
he's 60 I thought I can take and play
night f forward he's got 95 okay okay so
just go here prepare b3 also so take
with the pawn
yeah this is ambitious of course
at least it gives me a square on c3 for
the night
add this guy is a very dangerous
tactical plan it's um from a strategic
point of view here rally just something
to my position but he's very dangerous
always need to be alert for some for
some tricks to come k Bishop f4
come on I want to go to space you on the
King son he's got his pieces all tied up
here and this should be good really
check yeah he doesn't stand any passive
defense I know that so this is why you
played age five this is however quite
quite nice for me
hmm
don't I get this poor now I don't really
believe that there are some tactics that
can justify that
i have f also to to cover all this
f 493 something like that
yeah blacks completely busted here I
only need to be be precise it's still
possible to muddy the waters of course
okay neither three is my idea
so canvas I mean it could have played
night h7 and take evade but who wants an
exchange of this position at least I
don't I just want to keep this dominance
set up and to try to to win with a
meeting attack with that five yeah come
on I have all these pieces near the king
this must be the right way opening up
the G fall and to try to stay ahead on
the clock he can only win a single
porneia this doesn't really bother me
yeah this must be completely over I just
need to get more pieces near the king
especially the Queen the queen is the
the key of course so no f6 this winning
f6 Bishop f6
yeah of course it is winning what the
heck am I doing here I've got queen age
six just made black resigned yeah this
was dinner out yeah I think it was just
a qui tam quite miserable position from
the opening I have a very good score
against the sky if I don't allow any
technical tricks then it's usually quite
quite good for me yeah i think that
before so it's already a bit I don't
know it keeps the queenside closed and
now where there's nothing on the
queenside team now I think he needs to
somehow improve the defensive position
with them I'm not sure what clears i
think h5 vs it's almost a suicidal
checked just weakens your own position
and after that it's it's gone Queen f2
is even better according to the computer
but ok just just grabbing this cannot be
bad here it's just a just a deadly
attack coming here look g7 is already
checkmate ok let's set us just briefly
check it how this one ok yeah I
understand check
thankfully just a direct meet ya there
was so many many ways winning and this
was was one of them okay thanks for
watching